Carole Grimaud fondatrice du Sting Tang
Center for achat and Easton y aura plus
search à Genève également professeur en
géopolitique de la Russie à l'Université
de Montpellier bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur France 24 tout
d'abord peut-être un point sur cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne dans l'Est
et dans le sud du pays la Russie
apparaît sur la défensive que sait-on du
rapport de force sur le terrain alors
oui cette contre-offensive qui a
commencé il y a deux mois se poursuit
avec les les avancées la reprise de
l'imam sur le front de l'Est et Kerson
qui est là aussi
qui est le territoire des nombres
villages sont reconquis par les forces
ukrainiennes jusque profondément
finalement plus profondément encore que
au début de la guerre sur les lignes de
défense russe donc c'est ce sont des
avancées qui sont très importantes pour
les forces ukrainiennes parce que non
seulement sur le terrain c'est
reconquête il s'agit de de des
territoires qui faisaient partie qui
font partie de ce territoire reconquis
et annexé après le référendum mais aussi
psychologiquement les influent une une
grande un grand désarroi au sein de au
sein de l'armée russe des
questionnements dans la société russe
qui se questionne tout simplement sur
cette armée qu'on leur a qu'on leur a
projeté l'image de cette armée qu'on
leur a projeté depuis le début de
l'invasion comme une armée un pays donc
des questions se posent et des remous
donc c'est un politique et l'état-major
russe se font voir aujourd'hui alors on
va y revenir mais pour poursuivre cette
contre-offensive les États-Unis comme la
France d'ailleurs ont affirmé qu'ils
augmenteraient encore leur aide
militaire à l'Ukraine vous pensez que ça
permettrait à Kiev de réaliser des
avancées décisives
oui on l'a vu la contrepensive à ses
mise en place avec l'arrivée des almars
les fameux les fameuses armes à longue
portée qui ont été évidemment d'une
grande importance dans cette dans ces
contre-offensives donc les IMA alors les
Ukrainiens demandent depuis quelques
semaines des des armes avec une portée
plus grande 200 à 300 km et là les
États-Unis sont assez réservés sur ce
point-là et pour l'instant non pas donné
de réponse ne souhaitent pas leur
fournir ce type d'armes qui pourraient
qui pourrait être directement
toucher directement la Russie soit sur
le front de l'Est le soit sur la Crimée
donc c'est au niveau des armes donc on
voit le imas qui a été
probant et les armes que les Ukrainiens
récupèrent les armes russes que les
étudiants les
Ukrainiens récupèrent sur les
différentes les différents points de sur
les différentes villes et territoires
qui sont
donc parler Ukraine voilà donc pour
l'instant certaines reconquêtes de
villages n'ont pas été confirmées c'est
ce sont les annonces de voler ski ou de
l'état-major ukrainien il reste à
confirmer bien sûr tous ces tous ces
gains mais le momentum je dirais
momentum de cette contrefensive a été
atteint et atteint depuis dimanche et se
poursuit donc sur ces sur ces deux
fronts sur on affirme que plus de 200000
personnes ont été mobilisées en Russie
en deux semaines c'est donc l'annonce
tout à l'heure du ministère russe de la
Défense à quoi est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre pour les jours les semaines à
venir
alors c'est ces conquêtes c'est
reconquête ukrainiennes évidemment
ce se déroule avant l'arrivée de ces
mobilisés c'est bien le moment où le les
forces ukrainienne peuvent encore agir
et le font avant que ces mobilisé
arrivent sur le terrain alors on ne
connaît pas non plus la qualité de ces
mobiliser on l'a vu l'entraînement les
entraînements se déroulent mais parfois
il y a des soldats qui sont envoyés avec
très peu d'entraînement même pas du tout
on sait que le matériellement aussi pour
ces mobiliser donc on verra on verra
quand ils seront donc sur le sur le
terrain quand ils seront déployés mais
l'Ukraine en tout cas garde un avantage
aujourd'hui pendant ce temps la Douma
russe donc c'était tiers puis la chambre
haute du parlement russe aujourd'hui ont
approuvé le rattachement à la Russie de
ces quatre régions ukrainiennes où ont
été organisées les référendums
d'annexion
l'accélération du calendrier sur ce
sujet qu'on a pu constater c'est le
signe de la fébrilité du pouvoir russe
alors
les référendum étaient prévus depuis de
longues dates ils se sont mises en place
très rapidement on l'a vu après les
avancées ukrainiennes donc effectivement
la précipitation de ces de ces
référendums et le flou je dirais en ce
qui concerne les frontières de ces
référendum un flou qui est qui peut être
lu de façon la première étant donc cette
précipitation et la deuxième étant un
comment dire une volonté finalement de
ne pas attracer de frontières établies
parce que le gouvernement russe le
Kremlin s'autorise toujours à penser
qu'il peut reconquire des territoires et
même beaucoup plus que que les
territoires déjà défini au moment des
référendum donc ces deux lectures
différentes qui peuvent être qui peuvent
être plausibles alors revenons
maintenant sur ces critiques au sein
même du campus que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure des critiques qui se multiplient
face au recul des troupes sur le terrain
alors on peut évoquer par exemple celle
du dirigeant tchétchène ramzankaderov
qui a les samedis dernier je cite à
utiliser des armes nucléaires de faible
puissance en Ukraine de son côté le
patron de l'organisation para militaire
Wagner a aussi critiqué on l'a vu
l'action de l'état-major russe quelles
conséquence potentielles à ces critiques
alors la conséquence c'est on a vu que
peut-être les référendum avaient été
d'une conséquence justement par de cette
poussée
ultra nationaliste et de ses critiques
la mobilisation également donc on peut
se demander si effectivement le Kremlin
ne va pas suivre ou ne va pas essayer de
calmer ces critiques en
procédant à des à des Limoges au sein de
l'état-major c'est ce que réclame
kadyrope c'est ce que réclame également
il y avait gagné prix d'origine qui
réclame donc le un changement dans
l'état-major et même jusqu'au ministère
de la Défense puisque Serge Soko est
aujourd'hui vivement critiqué même dans
la presse prorus aujourd'hui les
critiques vont sont très très violente
sur cette armée que l'on leur a promis
et finalement il se demande même où est
passé l'armée russe
la question des mobilisations et
l'entraînement donc de ces soldats
paraissent trop faibles il se demande
pourquoi finalement ce ne sont pas les
militaires sous contrats qui sont qui ne
sont pas à envoyer finalement sur le
front et qui pourrait reconquérir donc
c'est c'est ces pertes voilà donc c'est
une c'est une des critiques également au
niveau politique au sein de la Douma on
critique l'état-major on critique la
stratégie militaire le ces problèmes de
communication et bien sûr avec les les
principaux responsables en tout cas
désignés comme tel c'est-à-dire le
général lapine qui qui était donc il
contrôlait cette région de Liman merci
beaucoup Carole Grimaud d'avoir répondu
aujourd'hui à nos questions sur la
situation donc en Ukraine